هل بدات اوكرانيا هجومها المضاد تنفي كيف
قائله ان خطتها تحب الصمت تتحدث موسكو
بنبره اقرب الى اليقين من ان الهجوم
المنتظر قد بدا بالفعل بالنظر الى ميدان
المعارك وتطورات الساعات الاخيره ثم تم ما
يحدث وكانه يهيئ لعاصفه كبرى لكن اي
السيناريوهات اقرب لهجوم اوكرانيا المضاد
قد تبدا الضربه الاولى من الجنوب وتحديدا
من المنطقه المحيطه بزابروجيا والتقدم الى
ميلوتوبول وصولا الى الشواطئ الشماليه
لبحر ازوف وهو ما سيؤدي الى تشتيت القوات
الروسيه في جنوب اوكرانيا والتحول غربا
لتتجمع في خرسون اذا حدث هذا فسيكون الجيش
الاوكراني قد قطع الجسر البري الروسي من
شبه جزيره القرم الى اقليم دومباس وقد سبق
ان اعلنت كييف ان قطع الامدادات اللوجستيه
للقوات الروسيه في الجنوب جزء اساسي من
الاستعدادات للهجوم المضاد وهو يفسر
الهجمات الاخيره التي هزت خزانات للوقود
في كراسنودار وميناء على بحر ازوف وبعد
عام من حسم روسيا لمعركه ازوبستال في
ماريوبول تعود القوات الاوكرانيه لمهاجمه
المدينه ما ينبئ بان جبهه حرب قد تفتح
مجددا هناك
وبالتزامن مع هجوم الجنوب قد يذهب الجيش
الاوكراني لتشتيت القوات الروسيه من خلال
شن هجمات بعيده المدى تستهدف وسط اقليم
دومباس يترافق ذلك مع معارك على الارض
بفتح جبهات ظنت روسيا انها حسمت مثل مدينه
باخموت وهو ما يبدو انه بدا بالفعل لتخفي
السلطات المواليه لروسيا بان الوضع في
محيط باخموت صعب للغايه اذ اعادت القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره على مساحات من قريه
برخوفكا على بعد تسعه كيلو مترات فقط شمال
باخموت كما تتحدث وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
هجوم اوكراني واسع النطاق جنوب دونيات شا
فيه ست كتائب اليه وكاتبه دبابات ومقاتلات
حربيه وسرب من الطائرات المسيره ووفقا
لنسق الهجمات خلال الاسابيع الخمسه
الاخيره يبدو ان التوغل داخل الحدود
الروسيه وتحديدا من منطقه بالقرود برا
وجوا خيار لدى الجيش الاوكراني 11 منطقه
داخل مقاطعه بالقرود تتعرض بشكل شبهي اما
لهجمات صاروخيه او بالطائرات المسيره او
توغلات لمسلحين يعول حلفائكيف في الغرب
كثيرا على قدره الجيش الاوكراني على احداث
تغيير بموازين القوه على الارض تقول
واشنطن ان جميع احتياجات اوكرانيا لهذا
الهجوم لببت وان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها فعلوا ومستعدون لفعل الكثير في
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله
اليوم يرى كثيرون ان الجيش الروسي هو ثاني
اقوى جيش في اوكرانيا معداته وجنوده واستر
اتيجيته العسكريه وروحه المعنويه نموذج
على حاله الفشل التقديرات تشير الى ان
روسيا فقدت اكثر من 100 الف قتيل في
الاشهر السته الماضيه ولكن بوتين يواصل
ارسال موجه تلو الاخرى من الروس الى ما
يسميه بمفرمه اللحم
اما الرئيس الاوكراني فهو يريد استعاده
حدود اوكرانيا المعترف بها دوليا بما فيها
شبه جزيره القرم لكن زيلينسكي لديه غايه
اخرى فهو يريد ان يبرهن على قيمه استثمار
حكومات اوروبا والولايات المتحده في الجيش
الاوكراني